we are told that jade is making pancakes
using flour eggs and milk this table
gives the cost per kilogram of each
ingredient and the amount in kilograms
that jade uses all right the total
amount jade spends on ingredients is six
dollars
write an equation that relates a b c and
d
pause this video and see if you can have
a go at this
all right now let's go through this
together so i like to do this in real
time so that you can see my thought
process so i'm i'm here with you right
now so let's see the total jade spends
and this is going to be on flour eggs
and milk is going to be six dollars so
one way to think about it is
the and i'll do this in different colors
the flour
dollars
plus
the eggs
eggs
dollars
or the amount that jade's going to spend
on eggs plus the amount that jade spends
on milk i'll call that the milk
dollars is going to be equal to the
total amount is going to be equal to
six
dollars and so what's the total amount
that jade is going to spend on flour
well we can just look right over here
0.9 dollars per kilogram times 8
kilograms so jay is going to spend 0.9 a
dollars i'm just going to multiply these
two things to figure out how much jade
spends on flour and so this is going to
be equal to and i'll lose the dollar
symbol just so we can focus on the
numbers and the variables 0.9 a
0.9 a and this is of course is going to
be in dollars which is important i'm
going to add dollars plus dollars plus
dollars to get dollars
now what about eggs
well the same notion 0.2 kilograms times
b dollars per kilogram if i take the
product of these two i'm going to get
0.2 b dollars or i could just think of
it as 0.2 b if i don't write the dollar
symbol
and then last but not least on milk
let me look at the product of these two
things of this
and of this so d kilograms at c dollars
per kilogram that's just going to be
c d dollars so plus
c d
and all of that is going to be equal to
six dollars
and we're done we wrote an equation that
relates a b c and d